where we hope we never again have to be
in the struggle against this pandemic
but here we are more than 142 000
americans were in hospitals as of sunday
with a coronavirus that's according to
the federal government the vast majority
unvaccinated now that was more than we'd
ever seen before the american academy of
pediatrics says more than 580 000
children tested positive for the virus
last week that is also an all-time high
this is not good pediatric cases have
almost tripled since the start of
december chicago schools reached a deal
late last night for kids to return
tomorrow they've been out of school for
five days millions of parents nationwide
face some very tough questions balancing
the benefits of in-person schooling with
the risk their kids could get sick in
the classroom
elise preston is reporting for us from
chicago elise good morning it's good to
see you
good morning gail great to hear you late
last night chicago teachers and city
officials agreed to have staff return
today and students to return in class
tomorrow now students will have missed
four days and five days a total a total
of five days by the time they walk
through the doors tomorrow
our goal throughout this entire process
was to both get our students back to
in-person learning as quickly as
possible
and prevent work disruptions the bitter
standoff grew contentious and heated but
late monday night compromise won the
city and the chicago teachers union
agreed to establish metrics where
individual schools will go remote if
there's a coveted outbreak resulting in
percentages of teacher absences there
will be more thorough contact tracing
and increased testing on staff and
students the district also plans to
provide kn 95 masks for students and
staff it's not a perfect agreement it
does include some important things which
are going to help safeguard ourselves
and our schools
while it's good news for the families of
the more than 340 thousand students
across chicago more than 5 000 schools
across the country have gone virtual
since the beginning of the year in
philadelphia over 90 schools switched to
remote learning due to staffing
shortages over omicron yes in the class
for her to learn but no because i don't
want to get sick in los angeles the
nation's second largest school district
classes resume today but students and
staff have to test negative for the
virus and so far more than 65 thousand
tests have come back positive for
parents like sharon obsessed her child
will be at home for the start of the
semester he started having symptoms and
i did a home test and he tested positive
last night he will be missing
the first
10 days of back to school sadly
now the entire teachers union in chicago
will vote on the proposed agreement
tomorrow it's or sometime later this
week it's unclear if students will have
to make up that missed time of five days
tony
elise preston leading us off from
chicago at least thank you very much